[Music]
everybody wants tres have hit me and
carry against each other so then when I
saw her I was like you know what let's
just end this right now and get a
picture together cuz we never in the
same place and like it never happened
Kelly Clarkson's squashing rumors that
she and fellow American Idol winner
Carrie Underwood have any bad blood
while chatting with et on the red carpet
ahead of the 2018 Radio Disney Music
Awards people always try and put it
together like we're like enemies I'm
agree know each other well it'd have to
be enemies so like anyway I went to get
a picture and then everybody lost their
mind what is it like to kind of have to
American Idol winners you and Terry both
here tonight and honored and Maddie Pope
who's present he knew you both together
right yeah it's cool it's like past and
present I love it yeah have you ever met
before I saw that you actually Instagram
thanking her for sending you some
athletic wear yeah her Kelly oh it's
really really rad she but how they
presented it was like to Lauren
another thing that's glorious so much
the youngest ever voiced winner and
Kelly's mentee Brynn cartelli looks up
to her
don't you
[Music]
the NBC coach was honored with the icon
award at the sixth annual awards show
what is your most iconic kelly clarkson
moment honor up tonight I think from all
the everything that she's ever taught me
I think even be everything that she's
done in to her success but I think off
camera and being a genuine person is the
most iconic thing that you could do so
much success but it's take them a lot to
be a really good person like I'm so
genuine and speaking of success Clarkson
is also a proud mama to two adorable
kiddos four-year-old River rose and two
year old Remington Alexander favorite
thing that your kids have done recently
that have just made you laugh I think
it's just the fact might my two-year-old
boy actually he's just now coming into
like really snuggling and connecting and
looking he's doing that looks me in the
eye and it's like super loving might my
four-year-old is exactly like Brett
she's got guys that's today she knows
what she wants and she's like just super
fun and like infectious so better yet oh
yes I love them but you're seeing him
play for me I got erupted at her it was
like River sing
[Music]
[Applause]